silencieux et paisible c'est ce que
souhaitait ce maraîcher bio il a lancé
grand jardin en 2021 à clairefontaine en
yvelines romain viennois détient cette
ferme centré autour de l'agriculture
biologique de moins d'un hectare ils y
pratiquent l'agriculture régénérative ce
qu'on essaie de mettre en place ici
c'est un système dans lequel le sol mais
aussi l'environnement dans lequel on est
s'améliore au fur et à mesure des années
en ayant plus de biodiversité en ayant
un sol qui est plus riche à la fois en
matière organique mais aussi en
diversité de la vie du sol et donc
arriver à recréer un cadre qui dont le
la richesse on va dire augmente au fur
et à mesure des amis
[Musique]
petit exemple de ce qu'on peut faire par
exemple ici ça va être la sueur des
haricots
on met en place un paillage
organique organise le mot peut faire
corps enfin c'est l'herbe
[Musique]
un autre exemple de pratiques qu'on est
en place pour pour construire un système
vertueux c2c de mettre en place dans nos
cultures à intervalles assez régulier ce
qu'on va plaider des planches fleury
alors on va y mettre des fleurs qui vont
avoir plusieurs fonctions ce petit
succession alors de soucis pois de
senteur
capucine bourrage pensée a pour fonction
de deux d'attirer les abeilles d'attirer
différents insectes qui l'a aussi vont
contribuer à construire un système qui
est équilibré quel saint leu maritime et
en place également des rotations et des
associations de culture un exemple
typique poireaux carottes et il aime
bien être à côté il ya des vrais effets
bénéfiques de les avoir ensemble là vous
avez des carottes des poireaux sont là
il manque encore des poireaux ici les
oignons c'est pas mal aussi à côté et
donc on fait un petit peu attention à ne
pas avoir en fait la même chose sur une
très grande surface à 44 ans romain
viennois venait du milieu de
l'hôtellerie il a tout quitté pour se
lancer dans le maraîchage il a également
un gîte et organise des activités de
découverte de sa profession je fais très
attention à ça justement de
d'arriver à créer un cadre complètement
préservée des gens qui viennent dans le
gîte ou pratiquer les activités mais
aussi les salariés qui sont à la ferme
il trouve un peu de bonheur et en
ressorte en se sentant meilleur des
séances de relaxation et méditation en
pleine nature sont également proposés
ici un grand jardin toujours dans le but
de se sentir mieux en sortant de ce lieu